[Music]
there's a lobster diver he gets in the
water
really early in the morning
and um you know
pretty normal morning
he's diving you know you got to go down
there pluck lobsters off the ocean floor
bring them up
so he's looking down
and he sees all these fish like swimming
around him and then all of a sudden out
of nowhere
he sees under him
like everything's getting dark
and then he looks above him
and there's nothing he's it's all dark
everything's dark
he was swallowed by a [ __ ] whale no
holy [ __ ] this was jonah and the whale
yeah dude he got swallowed by a [ __ ]
humpback whale bro and then what
happened and he says it's completely
black i could sense that i was moving so
he could feel the whale squeezing with
the muscles in his mouth around his body
and he was like am i in a great white
because he didn't [ __ ] know he's like
but then he saw no teeth
and then he didn't have any wounds so
he's like i stop all my [ __ ] limbs
and [ __ ] so he's just kind of swimming
in there and then like he's like dancing
on the tongue or whatever he's like
being he feels all these [ __ ] muscles
around him and [ __ ] it's like an alien
movie whoa and then yeah he said all he
could think to himself is that he's dead
he's a dead man
he's thinking about his kids and [ __ ]
he's thinking about how he'll never get
to eat his wife's [ __ ] again i know
and then he was about to eat a lobster
but he came and got eaten
yeah that's right so did he go out the
blow hole
no so he's so he's with he's got scooped
he's got scuba gear on he's struggling
and then the whale began shaking its
head so he could tell that he didn't
like what yeah because really who tastes
don't actually like doing that yeah he
has scoop gear on his [ __ ] this tastes
very aluminum
not delicious so he sees the light he
starts throwing his head side to side by
side because the you know the whale's
mouth is opening
and he's he's just thrashing around in
there and the next thing he knew he got
spit out oh good he's outside the water
oh
holy [ __ ]
straight to eating his wife's [ __ ]
here and he goes i'm gonna [ __ ] go in
your blowhole
and he go goes to shorts like 30 years
later did he eat the whales blowhole
ears too
so yeah i mean dude this is one of the
craziest [ __ ] stories i've ever read
what year is it
grabs the nearest newspaper
tell me what what year is it you son of
a [ __ ]
this guy hasn't lived here for years
the beach is named after him for a diver
that [ __ ] died what he's swallowed
he's like your wife's [ __ ] she she
died 30 years ago
you're a wife's
that's a great prank to pull if you saw
it happen with your friends and they're
like guys guys all right when that guy
comes out we're all gonna act like it's
2052.
newspapers quick i have a computer
it's like brett you're [ __ ] being too
crazy just chill a little bit where did
you get all that antique diving
equipment
stay character
oh my god that's worth a lot of money a
lot worth a lot of yen in this country
yeah that's good you're like you're this
you're the same age you were when you
went in
like holy [ __ ]
time fix continuum bends around those
[ __ ] huh that's such a
the whale's mouth is a portal to time
we've been waiting here for 30 years for
you
30 years we come back here on the
anniversary every year
that's why we have this bouquet of roses
what was that story with joining the
whale did he did he get swallowed and
then when he was spit back out was it a
different world that's the most jk
question i've ever heard he lives the
answer is going to be none of us really
know all it was was that he got he got
thrown by will and then he prayed to the
lord and then the will spit him out and
he credited you this isn't pinocchio
pinocchio did that as well
that's we're not talking about the same
didn't he pray in there too
they smoked him out that's what they did
they lit up fire
and then he started [ __ ] blowing
smoke out of his face and he just lied
and he's [ __ ] pulled created a
[ __ ] pinocchio nose and tickled him
and then he sneezed
monstrous sneeze that's what happened
how funny if that's the transition from
old to new testament i know it's because
he comes out it's a new testament you
know it's jesus christ people are going
to mix it all up right they're going to
mix that pinocchio and jonas
it's all the same
because they were all written during the
same time
they're going to look at that all the
stuff in history like in the future
they're just going to mix it all
together they're not going to know the
difference between parody
porn and a real [ __ ] history we're
already half of porn's our parody yeah
yeah that's what happened to jonah he
probably got spat out the whale and
[ __ ] a bunch of friends were like hey
dude you're pinocchio it's been a long
time
[Laughter]
so apparently this kind of thing
um has happened before but so freaking
rare
like almost basically non-existent um
and then he said that the um the
esophagus on the non-tooth whales is too
small to actually swallow a human being
what but they could get your mouth their
mouth around you which is what happened
so really the oil didn't have a choice
so you just spit it out yeah it's big
yeah he had to have been diving super
deep for those lobsters to be in an area
where the whale could swim ocean floor
hey you're you're a scuba steve like
you're you're you're a certified scuba
diver yeah you're a scuba diver right as
a certified scuba diver
how what is the deepest you've been
oh my god [ __ ] probably 50 60 clicks
where did you get scuba certified
um in in hawaii at this thing called
patty
so i was at it was at a resort in hawaii
and they and they like it's like a
five-day course that i took and then um
i just wanted to do it so i could scoot
or dive because you know what scooter
diving is no what's that
oh yeah the [ __ ] thing that yeah
you need to have scuba certification for
that you have to have scoop of
certification for that so that's all i
wanted to do that's the only reason you
got certified because i was like this is
kind of whack and i don't want my
friends to know because it's kind of
nerdy because i'm a really cool guy
and and i'll get beat up if they know
i'm a certified scuba diver but i want a
scuba dive yeah and keep it a secret i
thought you actually went down and scuba
diving no i did i thought you went down
to the floor and you scootered on the
ocean floor
you thought that huh
steve's gonna fight come a little closer
and tell me that personality is really
coming out
i mean that is also embarrassing
that would be funny how was it though
that i've seen me dude it's the sickest
[ __ ] i've ever imagined another guy
seeing that because you have to do any
work
it's a razor it's like it's like a
little motorcycle right like
[Music]
do you picture it it's like
guys are the submarines like
hey sally look over there guys scooter
in the bottom of the [ __ ] ocean floor
so did you then he pours out his drink
did you actually enjoy doing it it was
amazing it's well you because you just
point and then you're there already like
it's [ __ ] crazy wait do you have any
headgear or it's just the dome no you
have your full scoop of doubt oh yeah
it's just like a separate thing that has
like a [ __ ] rotating uh all that
bullet thing that you've got man oh that
one it's like it's like an engine um so
you turn it on and [ __ ] drag you have
you ever seen that it's cool that whole
thing where it covers the half of your
body and you just see people's lame ass
legs on the bottom with the flippers
yeah and then they have the tube that
goes to the boat the worst so those are
those those are kind of cool though
they're cool i think that there's
something about the because i've only
been scuba diving like once before maybe
twice but um there's this feeling that
you get when you get to breathe i think
that's like the first trip once you're
breathing underwater and you're like
wait a minute yeah i can stay here
you're already like [ __ ] i'm i'm man
i've conquered right here and see right
first you get that so then i can also
imagine having those things but being
able to maneuver
underwater like a human must be also a
different kind of like experience you
know what i'm saying well dude this [ __ ]
because like when you're getting
certified you have to like go down to
the bottom of the ocean floor and this
like shallower areas like 50 feet deep i
think and then i had to take off all my
gear
and like put it next to me and then like
not hold it and then put it all back on
oh [ __ ] well yeah so it's like it's like
you know it's legit skills [ __ ] with
your head a little bit but yeah you're
like learning how to how to if there was
an emergency or something how to get it
because most of it is like if it
malfunctions these mistakes are common
how to stay calm how to defeat rival
divers yeah how to establish fighting
yeah yeah knife fighting underwater how
to ride seahorses
coolest [ __ ] though was um hearing a
whale with my own ears whoa
that's [ __ ] crazy they were like out
there but i could hear it yeah
what did he say it was crazy yeah
that's what the whale would say whale
power
the whale says white power that's what i
thought you said i was like
i was like oh [ __ ] i i smell a whitey
he's like hey white power guy you're
saying without white power
steve i don't even know how to pick that
one that's [ __ ] funny though dude
well this is [ __ ] racist they are
racist yeah they have brains they get
they get sensitive i want to get scuba
certified now it's fine
let's go scuba diving what does it stand
for submerged something underwater blah
blah blah
do you have to get certified to do it uh
like the day that you go like it's all
kind of like tandem at first and then
you get certified in order to do it on
your own but then like i never did it
again it's not the same it's not like
being certified means you go like twice
a week or anything it's more like you
have to be certified in order to even
experience it and we're in california
and i'm way too much of a [ __ ] to swim
in those cold ass waters yeah yeah it's
way different got certified here but
that [ __ ] was like a week course oh like
a whole week maybe it's a day
yeah he's a week he's a weak person um
now five days is about right because i
did five days so every day yeah monday
to friday that's what i did imagine you
accidentally took the course to make you
the new teacher
at the end the guy goes hey have a good
life man
you're the santa claus now oh [ __ ]
it's on you but you gotta you gotta like
scuba in the right places right because
let's say like you you're certified you
have to scuba and stuff but you're going
to a place where it's just a drop off
it's just there's nothing that's in blue
nothing that's like not the feeling
necessarily that gives you that like you
want the clear like hawaii or like you
know anywhere clear there's a [ __ ]
coral reef there's like [ __ ]
stingrays and turtles and [ __ ] you know
you see all that because california is
just algae it's just rocks now micro
plastics
and there's always that feeling too like
once you go like at that drop off and
then everything it just goes into
nothingness there's also this really
[ __ ] scary weird yeah
it's cool but it's it's yeah it's have
you ever watched there's like um
uh
aircraft
guys are on air station aircraft
carriers right they they have a day
sometimes very rarely but where they can
go
into the water
and so if you watch these gopro videos
like these guys are swimming like like
on the top of just the abyss yeah and
when they look down it's like [ __ ]
nothing that's like this black water
going well it's clear but then all the
way down there it's just [ __ ] nothing
we went to swim with sharks it was like
that yeah no thank you yeah it's pretty
cool i do want to try that once getting
into one of those cages yeah you can do
it in hawaii youtube videos where the
sharks get in the cage and [ __ ] like
that too and they're like in there with
the diaphragm
just saw that the other day
really they get in the cage yeah one of
them it charged the cage so hard that it
bent the bar and got in and then they
were both thrashing around the but the
the shark was more freaked out trying to
get out yeah so the guy was safe but he
was in the cage with the shark he always
would like bend down in the corner i
wouldn't want to be that guy but i would
want to be in that group where it
happened to the other guy so i could
have a crazy story
oh i saw a guy get eaten yeah they don't
attack you they're like
they're just curious they come up
because the boats usually drop off like
they don't like it so they want to eat
that
but they're they're like five of these
tables you never you never did hydro jiu
jitsu hydro jiu jitsu not with [ __ ]
wildlife dude i swam with whale sharks
i swam with whale sharks in the
philippines that's sick yeah it was
pretty scary because they're just like
what they're big and then you're just
like oh isn't it a whale shirt like like
[ __ ] huge too it's pretty big there's
some small ones they got those like
square heads and stuff like that why
don't they
kill you they don't like yet no yeah
what what no i don't think whales like
we want to eat humans they eat uh krill
they don't eat people when you see oh
whale sharks sharks yeah yeah when you
say you swam with them how close are you
like right like right here you can touch
them like right here yeah in the
philippines it's my foot here and it was
like right below me wow are you like
scoob it in there or no snorkel oh
snorkel because they come to the surface
because they're like putting fish out
you know oh that's pretty cool it was
pretty cool it was scary though because
after i got off and went back onto the
boat i was like shaking i was like whoa
that was a trippy experience of
adrenaline remember the first time you
heard about like a whale [ __ ] busting
a nut and doing like 400 gallons of
sperm in one shoot yeah dude how does
everybody [ __ ] remember that you guys
are disgusting that's that's like bro
fact
all guys know that
do
[Music]